a rocket launch but with a difference  introducing starship it's 50 meters high  wheeze around 120 tons and could play a  key role in building a city on the moon  [Applause]  we're faced with a choice which future  do you want do you want the future where  we've become a spacefaring civilization  and are in many worlds and now out there  among the stars or one where we are  forever confined to earth and I say it  is the first and I hope you agree with  me for commercial space travel to be  viable spacecrafts need to become  reusable this is the plan for starship  which will go into orbit and dock with  tanker starships already there that will  enable it to gather the huge amounts of  propellant needed to travel to the moon  and beyond SpaceX hopes to put the  starship into orbit in six months time  and make it feasible for humans to  someday inhabit worlds beyond planet  Earth